so nice to be here in your city I love
Los Angeles a lot I love this city I'm a
big I'm a big cities person to be honest
with your loved cities hate small towns
they're all [ __ ] did you know did you
know that every small town is [ __ ]
it's okay I can prove it to you with one
very simple fact if small towns were
good they would have gotten bigger
because that's how towns work la didn't
start with this many people in it there
was like eight of here then you open in
an hour burger and they have a look
there's tons there's so many my fiancee
and I moved in together last year and
the deal when we moved in together was
she got to pick the area we moved into
and I got to pick the type of house that
was a great deal for me because my
fiancee for some reason loves old houses
I don't know why we live in Australia
but the older the house is the more she
finds it cute that house is from the
1840s isn't that cute
like now you know it's cute air
conditioning air conditioning scoop good
water pressure that's kid I guarantee
it's not happening in that old house see
we're gonna get in the shower and think
am i washing myself or is there an old
stroke victim through between the
dripping on me from the roof it's the
worst water pressure I've ever
encountered come on it's from the 1840s
isn't it adorable it's just adorable and
like they sang that word wrong it's
asbestos and
but I want to live there like my fiance
is fit and healthy which is very
bothersome to me because I'm neither fit
nor healthy like I'm sweating right now
and I've just been standing here for a
bit and already my body's like shut it
down champ that'll do that's enough for
one day you're only human and it's
enough standing there for a bit put your
feet up grab a beer you've earned it now
some of you may think that's a great
combination one person in the couple
cares about fitness and health the other
one doesn't
yin and yang what balance but no I don't
think that's how a couple should work
because my fiance constantly gives me
lifestyle tips based on her lifestyle
they make no sense to me to be like hey
Nick I was thinking for something a bit
fun instead of having eight beers today
how about don't she once said to me hey
Nick did you know that you can eat M&Ms
one at a time I said yeah you can also
eat rice by the grain but I'm not mental
I'm making poor choices right now come
on I'm over and done with quickly my
fiance keeps fit by doing a living room
workout she does them every day I'd
never join her in living room workouts
because they call living room workouts
it sounds a bit soft I realized recently
I'm the sort of idiot that will or will
not do something depending on how you
word that activity to me if it sounds
soft I'm not in but you take the same
activity make it sound tough and I'll do
it
that's how dumb I am and she knows this
she tricked me she knows I wouldn't do a
living room workout so I walked out of
the bedroom one morning she said hey you
want to try this indoor Spartan
challenge
yes yes I do
I love the movie 300 who knew that
Spartans worked out in front of the TV
this is gonna be great
she said first exercise mountain
climbers I said one of the own she said
very straightforward you're getting a
push-up position you bring your knees
back and forth as fast as you can do 50
I said you're on your honor I started I
got to 6 I stopped at 6 I was like that
that tapes that although 6 Alok she's
like yeah you're feeling the burn in
your thighs and your butt like now it's
actually hurting my stomach said your
stomach can i watch how you do mountain
climbers good said sure turns out though
America if you've got a bit of a gutting
you do mountain climbers all you're
doing is being yourself in the gut what
she serves it was how do 50 reps of fat
shame yourself stupid then go back to
your plural M&Ms at a scoop you mushy
disaster
[Applause]
you